[Music]
the avalanche of women who have come
forward against Harvey Weinstein all
began when Rose McGowan sounded off
against the movie mogul and today Rose
delivered her first public speech on the
subject of sexual assault it was an
astonishing display a fire and emotion
as Rose fights to change Hollywood we
are pure we are strong we are brave and
we will fight Rose McGowan raised her
fist in the air and called for the
entertainment industry to clean house we
are here we will not go away the actress
best known for her roles in charmed and
scream kicked off the women's convention
in Detroit rose was amongst the women
cited in an explosive New York Times
story earlier this month as having
settled sexual harassment claims against
Harvey Weinstein and then two weeks ago
McGowan claimed on Twitter that
Weinstein raped her the triggering has
been insane
the monsters face everywhere my
nightmare
Weinstein quote unequivocally denies
allegations of non-consensual sex
meanwhile actress actually judged who
also broke her silence about Weinstein -
the times was honored in New York last
night
we are definitely at a tipping point and
this will be the end of it if we decide
that's what we want
Judd was presented the truth to power
award by the Women's Media Center Oscar
winner Jane Fonda is one of the center's
co-founders this terrible scandal with
Harvey Weinstein is getting so much
attention I believe that it's actually
shifted things I feel things are
different
[Applause]
[Music]
you